[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend in allen das Wort vom
Generalstreik geht um in Deutschland das
dürfte übertrieben sein aber zumindest
beim Verkehr in diesem Land soll am
kommenden Montag nicht mehr viel gehen
weder auf Straßen und Schiene noch zu
Wasser oder in der Luft so wollen es die
beiden Gewerkschaften Verdi und EVG die
gemeinsam beschlossen haben für 24
Stunden in den Warnstreik zu gehen sie
fordern ein zweistelliges Plus bei den
Löhnen
historische Beeinträchtigungen so sagt
ein Gewerkschafter soll es insbesondere
bei der Bahn geben die
Flughafenbetreiber kritisieren die
Aktionen sprengten jedes vorstellbare
und vertretbare Maß wo man leskova
berichtet
von Mega Streik ist mittlerweile die
Rede fest steht der Weg zur Arbeit
könnte lang dauern am Montag Verdi ruft
zum 24-stündigen Ausstand auf allein im
Nahverkehr in sieben Bundesländern der
Tarifkonflikt eskaliert damit immer
weiter die jeweiligen Arbeitgeber
versuchen uns mit warmen Worten und
unzureichenden Angeboten abzuspeisen
und deshalb haben wir uns dazu
entschlossen mit vereinter Kraft in den
laufenden Tarifverhandlungen zu handeln
was das heißt werden auch Flugreisende
erfahren bis auf Berlin sollen alle
Verkehrsflughäfen vom Warnstreik
betroffen sein München etwa kündigt dann
schon am Sonntag gebe es keinen
regulären Betrieb mehr nicht viel besser
die Situation für Bahn Kunden von
Konzernseite heißt es der Fernverkehr
Werder am Montag komplett eingestellt
die drastischen Auswirkungen drohen weil
verdi und die Eisenbahn Gewerkschaft EVG
gemeinsam zum Arbeitskampf aufrufen es
werden ganze Schichten ausfallen
deswegen empfehlen wir den Reisenden die
am Sonntag mit Bussen und Bahnen im
Fern- und Nahverkehr unterwegs sind vor
allem im Fernverkehr rechtzeitig am Ziel
zu sein weil es durchaus Schichten geben
kann die bereits am Sonntagabend in den
Montag hineingehen die
Tarifverhandlungen Haken trotz konkreter
Angebote in beiden Fällen für den
öffentlichen Dienst verlangt Verdi 10,5
% mehr Lohn mindestens aber 500 €. die
Arbeitgeber bieten hier 5% in zwei
Schritten einen einmaligen
Inflationsausgleich von 2500 € in zwei
Schritten und eine Anhebung der Jahres
Sonderzahlung
Verdi hält das Angebot für ungenügend
insbesondere für mittlere und untere
Lohngruppen die Arbeitgeber halten
dagegen erklären den Bahnstreik für
unverhältnismäßig die Bahn Ärger zu dem
dass Ihre nächste Verhandlungsrunde erst
in einigen Wochen stattfindet wer war
denn dass die EVG an den
Verhandlungstisch zurückkehrt und wird
dort unmittelbar zu Lösung finden es
kann nicht ernst der Gewerkschaft sein
jetzt vier Wochen lang nicht verhandeln
zu wollen aber flächendeckend
zu leben egal wohin es geht es droht auf
jeden Fall ein beschwerlicher Montag der
Ärger hält sich bei vielen trotzdem in
Grenzen ich bin auch dieses Mal wieder
betroffen aber ich glaube es ist ein
wichtigeres Mittel um die Förderung
durchzubekommen
das ist gut die Gehälter müssen steigen
weil die Preise sind gestiegen kann ich
nachvollziehen aber für mich selber ist
anstrengend weil ich halt viel unterwegs
bin finde das ist ein legitimes Mittel
im Arbeitskampf was bleibt ist das
eigene Auto doch auch auf den Straßen
könnte Chaos drohen warnte ADAC wer kann
sollte Fahrten am kommenden Montag am
besten verschieben
wie viel Verständnis die Menschen in
diesem Land für einen solchen großstreik
haben parallel zu laufenden
Verhandlungen das wird sich tatsächlich
dann am Montag zeigen
bis Dienstag auch nicht mehr lange hin
wollen Europa-Parlament und Europäische
Kommission Klarheit haben wie es die
deutsche Regierung mit dem
Verbrennermotor hält dazu liegt ein fast
schon rechtskräftiges Gesetz vor dass
das Aus für Verbrenner ab 25 bedeutet
die Autoindustrie hat sich längst darauf
eingestellt aber dann legte die FDP per
Machtwort aus Berlin kurzfristig
Widerspruch ein und will extra Regeln
für sogenannte ifius in Brüssel kommt zu
Verwunderung jetzt Verärgerung über
diese Haltung und die Sorge Deutschland
könnte das gesamte Klimaschutzprogramm
der EU aufs Spiel setzen vom
Bundeskanzler erwarten Sie beim Gipfel
heute Aufklärung und Ansage Isabel
heute morgen gibt es noch die Hoffnung
dass der Streit um das Verbrenner aus
diesen Tag nicht dominieren wird
wir haben ja eine Agenda uns ja kein
Wunschkonzert wenn wir nach Brüssel
kommen wenn wir hier im Rad als
besprechen dann kommen
dann ja das ist nicht unsere unsere
Arbeit
und dann diskutieren zumindest am Rande
doch alle genau das was eben nicht auf
der Tagesordnung steht im letzten Moment
hatte Deutschland das bereits fertig
verhandelte Verbrenner aus ab 2035
gestoppt Berlin verlangt eine Ausnahme
für
klimaschonendes der Bundeskanzler stellt
sich heute ausdrücklich hinter die
Position der FDP hieran fest zu halten
es gibt klare verständungen in Europa
dazu zählt auch die von allen
unterschriebene Vorstellung dass es eine
Regelung geben sollte die Europäische
Kommission vorschlägt die sicherstellt
dass nach 2035
Fahrzeuge die ausschließlich mit E für
Holz betrieben werden kann weiter
zugelassen werden können das ist schon
Konsens wie genau dieser Konsens
aussieht ist allerdings nicht klar ein
Vorschlag der EU-Kommission sieht vor
das Fahrzeuge die ausschließlich mit
emissionsfreien Kraftstoffen betrieben
werden auch nach 2035 weiter hergestellt
werden dürfen allerdings nur wenn
technisch sichergestellt ist dass sie
nicht mit herkömmlichen Kraftstoffen
betrieben werden können die
EU-Kommission hat sich bewegt trotzdem
hat Deutschland bisher nicht zugestimmt
für viele gilt Deutschland nun als
wortbrüchig wir können Vereinbarungen
nicht einfach aussetzen es geht ums
Vertrauen zwischen den Institutionen und
die Glaubwürdigkeit unserer Verfahren
das finde ich sehr beunruhigend wenn ein
Mitgliedstaat so handelt was hindert
andere genauso zu handeln unsere gesamte
Entscheidungsfindung würde
auseinanderfallen wenn wir das alle tun
würden
die Sorge dass das deutsche Vorgehen
Schule machen könnte scheint sich zu
bestätigen auch andere wollen
nachverhandeln Italien und Österreich
etwa haben sich dem deutschen Veto
angeschlossen
wir werden uns weiter dafür einsetzen
und die Staaten unterstützen die dieses
Thema auf die Agenda gesetzt haben der
Europäischen Union und ist wichtig dass
wir den technischen Fortschritt einfach
weiter zulassen dass wir nicht
innovationsfeindlich sind Klimaschutz
braucht Innovation und Fortschritt der
deutsche Bundeskanzler betonte zwar man
sei auf einem guten Weg einen Kompromiss
zu finden bestätigt ist eine Annäherung
bisher aber nicht
Olaf Scholz sieht also alles auf einem
guten Weg guten Abend Ulf wie soll denn
dieser Weg jetzt genau aussehen ist das
jetzt klar geworden oder hat der
Bundeskanzler seine Sicht da exklusiv
ja leider hat er nicht gesagt wie dieser
gute Weg aussieht das hätte wirklich
sehr sehr viel hier interessiert nicht
nur die Journalisten sondern auch sehr
sehr viele Mitglieder der Europäischen
Union denn eigentlich sieht es eher nach
Krach aus nach Eskalation die letzten
Stunden haben sich die deutschen doch
viel Kritik anhören müssen entweder
offiziell und dahinter vorgehaltener
Hand da fallen Worte wie ein Wort pro
Vertrauen Vertragsbruch Destabilisierung
Europas all das wird mit Deutschland
verbunden Olaf Scholz wehrt sich das hat
er zu Beginn gleich deutlich gemacht und
sagt es hätte Versprechen gegeben dass
eben diese e-fuels in den Vertrag drin
ist das hätte die Kommission zugesagt
und die hat gerade vor wenigen Minuten
eine Antwort darauf gegeben die schon
sensationell und ziemlich einmalig ist
sie hat gesagt dass es diese
Versprechung eben nie gegeben hat sprich
eigentlich dass der deutsche
Bundeskanzler hier die Unwahrheit sagt
also eine solche Sackgasse wo die
Kommission sich direkt gegen Deutschland
stellt das ja ein sehr Wichtiges oder
vielleicht das mächtigste Land in Europa
ist ist schon nicht ziemlich einmalig da
wird natürlich jetzt auch viel Druck
aufgebaut aus Europa Richtung
Deutschland warum sieht denn die EU
plötzlich sogar ihr gesamtes Klimapaket
in Gefahr
ja der Einsatz ist einfach gigantisch
hoch wann weiß jetzt dass es bei diesen
ganzen klimapaketen um sehr sehr viel
geht weil dieser Wandel der Gesellschaft
auf Klimaneutralität wird Gewinner haben
aber es wird auch Verlierer haben und es
wird jedem Land viel zumuten und das ist
ganz entscheidend dass man sich auf die
Absprachen verlassen kann deswegen sind
so viele sauer auf Deutschland und
dieses Auto verbrenner motor Thema ist
ein hochsensibles quasi ein Symbol Thema
man hat gehofft dass man das hinkriegt
und damit quasi Schwung in alle weiteren
Klimaverhandlungen bringt und jetzt
sieht es ein bisschen nach dem Gegenteil
aus wir haben das ja gerade im Beitrag
gesehen dass jetzt immer mehr Länder
Nachfahren wollen den Kompromiss also
aufschnüren und damit droht dann das aus
vom verbrenner motor eben dem aus dem
ich nicht zu kommen und das wäre dann
eine riesen Problem für weitere
klimapakete weil dann das Vertrauen
wirklich zerstört wäre also es bleibt
weiter hoch interessant für heute Abend
erstmal ganz herzlichen Dank nach
Brüssel und dann nehmen wir jetzt auch
noch unsere wirtschaftsexpertin hier mit
dazu in Frankfurt am Main an der Börse
Valerie Haller guten Abend Valerie
manche reiben sich ja die Augen wie sehr
und warum sich insbesondere die FDP aber
jetzt offenbar auch mit Rückenwind durch
den Kanzler bei diesem Thema so
verkämpft wie wichtig wären denn der
deutschen
autoindustriever brennermotoren mit
e-fuels der Mehrheit der Autokonzerne
wohl eher nicht ganz so wichtig viele
investieren nämlich gar nicht mehr in
die Verbrenner Mercedes sagt zu uns
sogar klipp und klar das Thema ist durch
auch Audi Volkswagen und Opel steigen
aus der verbrennertechnologie aus
freiwillig ifuels sind stand jetzt
aufwendig energieintensiv und deutlich
teurer als Benzin und Diesel nicht ganz
abgeneigt oder zumindest Verfechter der
technologieoffenheit des BMW die
Münchner setzen neben Strom auch auf
Wasserstoff und damit überzeugtesten
scheint noch Porsche zu sein in Chile
hat der Autobauer eine ifuelsabbrig
gebaut und leistet die Produktion in
kleinem Maßstab größte Herausforderung
noch die Kosten bei der Herstellung ein
Problem ist auch das bislang nur wenig
künstlicher Sprit hergestellt wird und
die Konkurrenz um den knappen Stoff
deswegen ziemlich groß sein dürfte
Flugzeuge Schiffe und LKW brauchen
vermutlich künstlichen Sprit weil sie
sich kaum oder gar nicht elektrifizieren
lassen also manche wittern eine Chance
den Verbrenner länger am Leben zu halten
viele aber sind doch eher skeptisch
interessante Zusatzinformationen dank
dir Valerie
und der weitere Blick auf die Welt jetzt
und da gucken wir zunächst nach Israel
wo der von allen Bibi genannte
rekordministerpräsident ernst macht mit
einem Gesetz das wie zugeschnitten
scheint auch
wie selbst Hanna ja ganz genau in Israel
hat das Parlament ein Gesetz
verabschiedet das eine Amtsenthebung des
Regierungschefs deutlich erschwert
konkret sieht es vor dass der
Ministerpräsident nur dann abgesetzt
werden kann wenn er sich selbst oder
wenn drei Viertel der Kabinett
Mitglieder ihn wegen gesundheitlicher
oder psychischer Gründe als
regierungsunfähig einstufen
Korruptionsvorwürfe wie ist sie gegen
Nathan Yahoo gibt reichen nicht aus das
Gesetz ist Teil der umstrittenen
Justizreform der rechtsreligiösen
Regierung gegen die seit Monaten
protestiert wird auch heute wurden
wieder landesweit Straßen blockiert wie
hier in Tel Aviv
die Ukraine bereitet offenbar in der
Nähe der von russischen Truppen fast
vollständig umzingelten Stadt bachmut
eine Gegenoffensive vor das teilte der
Befehlshaber der ukrainischen
Bodentruppen auf telegram mit erst
gestern hatte der ukrainische Präsident
selenski die Front bei bachmut besucht
heute reiste er in die Region im Süden
des Landes wo er sich unter anderem ein
Bild von der zerstöre störten
Infrastruktur machte
mit landesweiten Demonstrationen
Blockaden und Streiks haben mehr als
eine Millionen Französinnen und
Franzosen erneut gegen die Rentenreform
protestiert dabei kam es in Paris und
anderen Städten zu gewaltsamen
Ausschreitungen die Polizei setzte
Tränengas und Wasserwerfer ein laut
Frankreichs Innenminister da man da
wurden mehr als 120 Einsatzkräfte
verletzt und mehr als 80 Personen
festgenommen die Wut der
Demonstrierenden richtet sich auch gegen
den französischen Präsidenten macron der
das Paket ohne Parlamentsabstimmung
durchgesetzt hat ihre Form sieht vor
dass das Renteneintrittsalter auf 64
Jahre angehoben wird
Außenministerin baerbock hat Nord
Mazedonien die Unterstützung
Deutschlands im EU-Beitrittsprozess
zugesichert es müssten alle Hebel in
Bewegung gesetzt werden damit der
Prozess rasch weitergehe erklärte die
Ministerin bei ihrem Besuch in der
Hauptstadt Skopje auch mit Blick auf
eine mögliche russische Einflussnahme
auf das Land zudem verwies baerbock auf
nötige Reformen
nordmazedonien ist seit 2005
EU-Beitrittskandidat am Nachmittag
reiste nach Georgien auch hier soll es
um den angestrebten EU-Beitritt gehen
der Vorsitzende der SPD in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Thomas Kutschaty hat
seinen Rücktritt erklärt nachdem er
gestern mit seinem Vorschlag für eine
neue Generalsekretärin parteiintern
gescheitert war kutadi der auch
stellvertretender SPD Bundesvorsitzender
ist hat er bei der NRW Landtagswahl vor
10 Monaten als Spitzenkandidat ein
historisch schlechtes Ergebnis
eingefahren am 6 mai muss ein SPD
Landesparteitag nun über die künftige
Führung entscheiden
[Applaus]
es gibt im Nahen Osten an besonders
legendären Imbissbuden häufiger ein
großes Schild zu sehen darauf steht wir
sind das Original Vorsicht von
Nachahmern das Schild führt meist nicht
viel weiter weil der Imbiss mit
demselben Namen etwas weiter weg auch so
eins hat und dasselbe drauf steht
bei der AFD im Bundesland Bremen ist es
ähnlich es gibt sie gleich zweimal
sozusagen zumindest behaupten gleich
zwei konkurrierende afd-listen jeweils
von sich sie seien die echte Hintergrund
seit vergangenem Jahr streiten sich zwei
AFD landesvorstände welcher von ihnen
legitim ist dem Landeswahlausschuss in
Bremen hat jetzt der hat jetzt keine von
beiden zugelassen und damit darf die AFD
bei der Bürgerschaftswahl am 14 mai gar
nicht antreten die Reaktionen hat keine
klassisch in den letzten Monaten führte
die AFD in Bremen ein Lehrstück der
selbst zerfleischung auf heute nun
konnte man in den Gesichtern ablesen es
gibt bei diesem Streit nur
innerparteiliche Verlierer der Bremer
Landeswahlausschuss streicht heute
nämlich kurze Hand beide konkurrieren in
Gruppen die sich für die wahre AFD
halten um sehr genehmig hier links und
Heinrich Lühmann rechts im Bild von der
Wahlliste wir kamen dazu dass kein
einziger Wahlvorschlag das Landesebene
wirksam ist einer hatte den Mangel das
nicht ordnungsgemäß zur
Aufstellungsversammlung eingeladen wurde
der andere Wahlvorschlag hatte den
Mangel das nicht er nicht von den
richtigen Vorstandsmitgliedern nach
Auffassung des Ausschusses unterzeichnet
war was die verfeindeten Lager davon
halten dass sie jeweils andere Gruppe
meint sie würde die AFD Bremen
repräsentieren wurde während der Sitzung
mehr als deutlich das ist Betrug auf
offener Bühne oder das ist komisch
Klingenberg aber die Liste des Hobby
Vorstands die ist ja sowieso raus sie
können ein bisschen beschweren diese
lustig sind
da wird ja nichts warum kommen doch
einstimmig war der Landeswahlausschuss
der Meinung keines der beiden afd-lager
zur Landtagswahl zuzulassen Reaktion ich
bin enttäuscht weil unsere Liste hatte
nur einen Mangel die das Mangel war die
Einladung
wir hatten öffentlich eingeladen und
durch ein Mehl des Bundesvorstandes
waren alle Mitglieder erreicht und somit
gingen wir davon aus dass unsere Liste
akzeptiert wird wir werden dann auch die
wahlanfechten wir werden vor Gericht
gehen wir werden jede Möglichkeit die
wir die uns zur Verfügung stehen nutzen
um dann eben auch Gerechtigkeit zu
bekommen der wahlbereichsausschuss hatte
zunächst den afd-wahlvorschlag für
Bremerhaven zugelassen nun wurde aber
auch diese Entscheidung mit der heutigen
höheren Instanz gekippt das Bremer
Wahlrecht sieht vor wenn im Wahlbereich
Bremerhaven oder im Wahlbereich Bremen
die 5% Hürde übersprungen wird kommt die
Partei in den Landtag doch heute wurden
für die AFD alle Möglichkeiten versperrt
in die Bürgerschaft einzuziehen mit
möglichen nachspielen dann im
schlimmsten Fall hätten wir Berliner
Verhältnisse das heißt sozusagen wenn
das ganze dann nach der Wahl erst
festgestellt wird und es wird
festgestellt man hätte eine der beiden
Listen zu lassen müssen ja dann waren
sozusagen die Bedingungen nicht
gleichwertig bei dieser Wahl für alle
teilnehmenden Parteien im Wald
Vereinigung
und dann müsste eventuell die Wahl
wiederholt werden das wäre natürlich
sozusagen die schlechteste Szenario was
wir uns vorstellen können die
Wählervereinigung BÜRGER IN WUT hofft
nun darauf am 14 mai Sammelbecken für
Protest Fehler im Land Bremen zu werden
jetzt wo die AFD nicht zugelassen ist
im Osten Deutschlands steht die AFD
anders da und sie sorgt gerade bei der
CDU für einiges an Kopfzerbrechen wie
einer starken AFD begegnen ihr Stimmen
ab jagen und dennoch CDU bleiben eine
Partei auf der Suche nach sich selbst in
mehreren Regionalkonferenzen diskutiert
sie über Ideen für ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm und da kommt die Frage
auf ob die CDU sich zwei Perspektiven
dazu leisten kann eine Ost eine West
heute will der Parteichef seine Basis
hören in Schkeuditz bei Leipzig mattes
felddorf ist dabei
der Auftritt ist glattparteitagsreif
Friedrich Merz und die Partei Prominenz
ziehen ein zur Regionalkonferenz in
Schkeuditz bei Leipzig ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm will man erarbeiten
und März will der Union seinen Stempel
aufdrücken
in den letzten Jahren hat die CDU den
Kontakt zu ihrer Basis verloren das neue
Grundsatzprogramm soll diese entstandene
Lücke auch zwischen Ost und West wieder
schließen ich glaube das ist doch das
was eine Partei spannend und ausmacht
dass es Thüringer und Sachsen gibt die
sagen Mensch bei uns sind dass die
Bürger vielleicht anders als bei euch
die Menschen im Osten ticken anders und
sind eine Art Seismograph für ganz
Deutschland so schreibt man es der
CDU-Spitze in Schkeuditz entstandenburg
Friedrich Merz ist der hoffnungsträgerei
derjenigen die dabei waren sich
abzuwenden von der CDU seit einem Jahr
versucht er seiner Partei wieder mehr
Profil zu geben durchaus auch mit
Reizthemen wie in einer klaren
Abgrenzung von der AFD oder der
Klimapolitik die überragende Frage der
Menschheit vor diese heute jenseits von
Krieg und Frieden gestellt wird
ist die Umweltpolitik ich die Bewahrung
der Schöpfung die Vermeidung eines
weiter voranschreitenden Klimawandels
und lassen mich das auch in dieser
Klarheit und Deutlichkeit sagen
niemand von uns sollte bestreiten dass
dies ein wahrhaft ernsthaftes großes
Problem ist für den Mann der als
One-Man-Show den Parteivorsitz erobert
hat ist seine Rolle ein Dilemma der CDU
seinen Stempel aufdrücken und
gleichzeitig breiter aufstellen ich weiß
doch dass ich
keinen Erfolg habe wenn ich in der
Partei oder in der Bundestagsfraktion
alles selber mache wir brauchen
Gesichter wir brauchen Gesichter die
sich mit Themen verbinden und wir
brauchen natürlich auch jüngere
Gesichter als ich es bin doch die
anderen Gesichter gerade die der OST CDU
formulieren auch mal handfester und
klarer und da wird auch mal angedeutet
dass die ampelpolitik irgendwie an die
Politik der DDR erinnert
wer schon mal eine sozusagen
autokratische Herangehensweise von
Politik erlebt hat der hat ein
hohesensorium entwickelt dafür ob in
gewisser Weise ähnliche Mechanismen
wieder politisch gespielt werden sollen
es scheint eine Arbeitsteilung die gut
funktioniert März der Parteichef der
präsidiert die anderen die polarisieren
heute super rede ich glaube das ist
schon richtig beschrieben mit rede mit
Kompass ich bin sehr gespannt was am
Ende dabei herauskommt in hoffentlich
zwei Jahren schauen wir mal
einbezogen werden und es gibt natürlich
ein bisschen nochmal so ein Schub für
die nächste Arbeit für die nächsten
Jahre jetzt der offene Streit bleibt
heute außen Schkeuditz vielleicht ist
ein Grundsatzprogramm auch zu
grundsätzlich aber die Kluft zwischen
parteispitz und Basis scheint kleiner
geworden
Donnerstagabend bei uns noch mal Johanna
ja und da schauen wir auf die
Frühjahrskonferenz der
agrarministerinnen und Minister bei den
Beratungen im schleswig-holsteinischen
Büsum geht es noch bis morgen unter
anderem um das von der EU-Kommission
geplante Verbot von Grundschleppnetzen
in Meeresschutzgebieten dagegen
protestierten zahlreiche Fischer in
direkter Nähe zum Tagungsort sie
befürchten bei einem Verbot das Aus für
ihren Berufszweig und Schleppnetze
stehen in der Kritik weil sie den
meeresboten beschädigen können
im US-Bundesstaat Kalifornien sind bei
Unwettern mindestens fünf Menschen ums
Leben gekommen im großraumlaus Angeles
wurden durch einen Tornado Dächer von
mehreren Gebäuden sowie Autos stark
beschädigt schon seit Januar regnet es
in Kalifornien ungewöhnlich stark dabei
kommt es immer wieder zu
Überschwemmungen und Erdrutschen
für gläubige Musliminnen und Muslime ist
heute ein besonderer Tag denn der
Fastenmonat Ramadan hat begonnen das
bedeutet dass Erwachsene Muslime von
Morgendämmerung bis Sonnenuntergang
unter anderem auf Essen und Trinken
verzichten endet wird der Ramadan in
vier Wochen mit dem Fest des
Fastenbrechens
ja all unseren muslimischen
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern Ramadani
wenn eine Band mehr als 100 Millionen
Platten Musikkassetten CDs Downloads
verkauft hat dann ist sie erstens schon
verdammt lang im Geschäft und zweitens
verdammt erfolgreich über Depeche Mode
muss ich nicht viel sagen außer dass die
Band ein neues Album hat und viel zu
verarbeiten Schmerz Sehnsucht Abschied
aber vor allem Trauer und Tod Nicolette
Feiler Tulln hat mit Depeche Mode
gesprochen wo sie jetzt nur noch zu
zweit sind
Depeche Mode erstmals als du live for
fans
Zeit ist flüchtig
[Musik]
sehen wir was sie bringt singt Dave gun
fast trotzig in einen neuen Song eine
tanzbare Ermahnung zu leben
alles wird irgendwann ein Ende haben für
jeden von uns
in der westlichen Welt missbilligen wir
das irgendwie schieben das oft weg aber
es ist doch für jeden von uns so
würde ich sagen
entschieden uns ganz auf Musik zu
fokussieren und nicht in unserem Elend
zu schwelgen
das Elend meint den plötzlichen Tod von
Andy Fletch Fletcher vor knapp 10
Monaten er war ihr Keyboarder der dritte
Kopf mit Begründer und Kids der Band
fährt sich lange Jahre der Schock sitzt
noch tief auch bei unserem Gespräch
[Musik]
ich sag immer die fletsch war der größte
halt für uns für die Band für Martin für
die Pesch Mode sein Tod ist unfassbar
warum es erinnert an die eigene
Sterblichkeit und all die Leute um einen
herum die Freunde die Familie man fängt
an sehr viel mehr über den Tod
nachzudenken
Melancholie gehört zum Geschäft von
diepeche Mode weitermachen auch für
fletsch wie sie betonen wie geschmiedet
ist da der Album Titel Memento Mori
bedenke deine Sterblichkeit ein Abgesang
auf Depeche Mode nein aber des typisch
ist doch unsere Tradition ja unsere DNA
wie war
1981 katapultiert als just Candy nach
vier Jungs aus England in den city-pop
Himmel
[Musik]
aus vier wurden drei Band Mitglieder
immer schon haben die Depeche Mode
potentiell Band auslöschende Ereignisse
überstanden
1996 war Garn aufgrund einer Drogen
Überdosis der erste kleine tote der Band
für zwei Minuten die Frage drängt sich
auf was heißt es tot zu sein
[Musik]
für mich war da nichts zu denken dass es
so etwas Erstaunliches gibt wie das
Leben nach dem Tod ist schon ziemlich
gierig es war einfach das Ende wie das
Ende einer Batterie Schluss aus das
einzige was ich in dem Moment wirklich
fühlte war es war falsch dass ich
versucht habe alles irgendwie zu
manipulieren
[Musik]
Depeche Mode so die zeitig solo lebendig
Memento Mori ist sicher nicht das Ende
[Musik]
ja zum Glück nicht das Ende spannende
Diskussion nach uns bei der Kollegin im
Maybrit Illner Heizung Strom Ampel
Streit Klima retten auf die harte Tour
Fragezeichen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute ist Welttag der
Meteorologie
1873 also vor 150 Jahren gab es den
ersten meteorologie-kongress in Wien
daraus entwickelte sich dann am 23 März
1950 die Weltorganisation für
Meteorologie dieser Geburtstag ist ja
immer im Frühling meistens ist es da ja
auch schon recht mild aber bei uns wird
es jetzt noch mal markant kälter vom
Norden und es kommt heute Nacht schon
kräftiger Regen an der breitet sich hier
bis morgen früh bis zur Ostsee aus am
längsten trocken bleibt es noch in
Sachsen und in Bayern bei einem starken
super recht kräftigen stürmischen Wind
aus südwestlichen Richtungen und so wird
das eine milde Nacht mit 13 Grad am
Oberrhein und 7 Grad am alten Rand und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
dann bei 11 bis 17 Grad und der Regen
der Nacht verabschiedet sich mehr und
mehr in Richtung Osten dann lockern die
Wolken auf es gibt kräftige Schauer und
Gewitter und am längsten regnet es noch
ganz im Süden und auch im Osten
Deutschlands der Wind ist immer noch
kräftig dreht allerdings ein bisschen
und zwar auf West südwestliche Richtung
und dann kommt der Samstag der bringt
kräftige Regenschauer und Gewitter mit
bei Temperaturen von 9 bis 14 Grad einem
stürmischen Wind am Sonntag ziehen über
die Mitte und den Süden kräftige
Regenfälle hinweg im Norden wird schon
Freund hier dreht der Wind auf Nord und
dann kann es am Montag selbst im
Flachland vorübergehend noch mal weiß
werden guten Abend